[Music]
what i would say though with with star
wars it's a different kettle of fish
because this is not a long-running tv
show so you've got the original trilogy
very much george lucas's vision um
but
he didn't have three movies planned out
initially he um he had some ideas
and it it came about
as much a mixture of his ideas and also
editors editors doing a massive amounts
of work reigning him in um and different
directors for the last two movies then
the the prequel trilogy came out and
don't get me wrong i it's not a
masterpiece in my opinion but there's a
lot of good things going on there's a
lot of heart
and i feel like the sequel trilogy for
me
there isn't any heart in it i feel like
it's it's it's death by committee i feel
like you've got a
a bunch of people sat there throwing out
ideas you know and um and basically it's
it's the product of a writer's room that
isn't necessarily
styles fans they're people that are
hollywood executives who want to make a
a popular science fiction movie we're
going to kill
which are the original cast are we going
to kill in this film
and then which of the thing and there's
just it's been very formulaic
that's the thing
no let's leave jar jar alone he must
live to the to the heat death of the
that's the point
i mean it was just what about those
bloody little penguin things oh i'll
just you know uh
chewy roast them and over s uh
where an open spit was just yes i love
that
for me i think one of the issues both
star trek and star wars has is a lack of
cohesive vision
so
um giving you guys some examples so um
deep space nine ran for seven seasons
right
and i had three producers
tng ran for seven seasons i had five
producers right
star trek discovery season two which for
me was where it went wrong had 14
producers
[Music]
for one season
11 producers right and we all know with
star wars that it had an entire team of
producers and writers and all of that
and i i feel like in a way these guys
have met death by committee because i
know star trek you know it was george
lucas but he had a bit of help however
you look at how the mandalorian went
when it had a a proper show runner who
was passionate about the subject
flipping fantastic you know and and you
look at initially when they relaunched
star trek with discovery season one
yeah there was a bunch of producers but
discovery season one was a really good
season of star trek and i think what's
happened is that they've almost got to a
death by committee thing where they're
it's basically
can i swear
a little bit don't say this poor
planning piss for planning basically
they they start the series and they've
got no plot outline and then what ends
up happening is and this particularly
happened with picard is they have
writer's room drama where basically
everybody's going in there and they've
all got ideas and instead of the
plot serving the scenes the scenes are
serving the plot so they come up with oh
wouldn't it be cool if we had a ball
cube and another renegade uh romulan
group that's
star wars you know started out with you
know has the same kind of problems i
mean you know when uh episode four five
and six
you know lucas directed the first one
and other people directed the the
sequels while he was
you know
getting you know lucasfilm off the
ground and uh the effects and everything
else was going on
when it came to episode one two and
three but there's a long period of time
in lucas's life which went from the end
of episode
six to when he started with one
is by the time they got to one knew was
nobody on in hollywood that would tell
lucas no
yeah
yes star wars episode 4 was um
edited by his ex-wife
and i'm pretty sure she told him no a
lot but it was really tight so it was
just collaborative effort all the way
through i mean lucas will come on the
set for episode five and six and well
this is what and this is this is sure
but you know the directors did the
directing thing however
um as you were saying storm it's a case
of though yes there's lots of people
involved but it's sort of one man's
vision that has been moulded into
something constructive as opposed to
nowadays it's an entire room full of
people with conflicting ideas that all
want to
get whatever they want out there
yeah i agree
but i think across the three films in
particular there's three very different
i don't think there's like a um identity
to star wars i think there's a style i
think there's a cinematic style to the
films and you can pretty much
go wherever you want with the stories
but it's got to feel like star wars yeah
i agree
the three films though there's a very
different sort of styles the um the the
one is basically it's like a comedy
there's a little this way comes out like
on all these sort of bits it was very it
didn't it's like the star wars slap like
comedy
well i i mean i've i'm sorry i feel like
i'm i'm constantly talking over you guys
but i i i fully agree with you i think
um
one of the main issues with
i miss this actually applies for both
star trek and star wars is that
they don't take themselves seriously
enough
or in the case of the card they take
themselves too seriously so what i would
say there is in the initial so let's
look at it from both angles so we look
at star wars right
it's contextual comedy why do people
laugh you know people laugh when
princess leia calls han solo a nerf
herder and and kisses her brother
um you know um versus in the new star
trek series it's like oh you're your
mother
and it's like
all that's happening there is you're
taking away from the severity of the
situation because in the initial series
all of the comedy was contextual so it
was based around the situation you were
in whereas what they're what they've
tried to do in the sequel trilogy is
inject comedy in like a marvel style
with lots of quips
and that isn't star wars that's marvel
because that's how marvel has been since
the beginning but that's not star wars
it's star wars is supposed to be taken
seriously darth vader serious threat
grand moff tarkin serious threat the
emperor serious threat if you've got one
of your like squadron leaders and
they're making your mama jokes
against them
that is diminishing the threat of the
enemy which diminishes the threat in the
story which which makes the whole thing
unravel because you're not threatened by
the bad guys then are you
because they're a joke to the audience
you know
[Music]